&gt;&gt; Grant is still at the Udacity Glasses Expo. And to get people more excited
about his family of glasses wiper products, he's decided to add a game to his
booth. Anyone who wins the game gets a free pair of deluxe glasses wipers, the
ones with the awesome curlicues on them. The game is pretty simple. The person
playing uses this giant slingshot that Grant built to try to get a ball through
a hoop that's attached way up high on the ceiling. Grant has another idea of a
way to soup up his booth though. The game isn't quite enough for him. A gigantic
sign with his brand name on it. That way no one will ever forget what his
company is called. The question is, where should he hang it? He needs to make
sure that it doesn't get in the way of shots from the slingshot that would
otherwise have gone through the hoop.